um I know some of you are not watching
and and and using the post and the patri
I moved everything in there there's lots
of reasons for it okay so I encourage
you that you watch the one on the
seizure versus
Lincoln
okay um in that I post several things
that you can tell several bullet points
that you can tell am I winging am I just
doing external iido am I doing internal
iido okay and you want to see these
things in your own art what are you
doing
okay uh I can't fix what I can't tell
like I I have to bring awareness to the
problem before I find a solution
okay so trying to give you pointers
identifiers am I doing that did I just
move the arm and the center didn't move
okay and was I supposed to there and
then but those are just easily
identifiable things but anyone who knows
what's going on you you would see other
things okay so for
example it when when I'm walking around
like this anyone should be able to see
that there's tension in the glutes and
there's tension in my lower legs like
I'm walking around like this this is how
a lot of I keto people they're they're
all like ahead right and they're doing
like anyone could see that I'm on top of
the map not sunk into the mat and then
you know it would look
for you see the metacarpal
grabbing you see you you would see that
and then you could tell I'm on the front
side of the foot like I'm falling this
way do you see maybe even from this
angle over here the heel is up he so
there's no
way that the energy is going through me
it's bouncing with me going working okay
so in this drill that we're trying to do
here like this can't be it like that
can't be it you're you're forward on
your weight you got tension in your
glutes right the shoulders are locked
back all Weir the small of the back is a
f
so
no fix
yourself okay the the feet are spread
and flat which just happens from
releasing release release
release the shoulders are not back
here
relax you're just hanging okay so I feel
it then I go and he's going to start
that's a little hard for your your
partners here today start with nothing
start with nothing go back go back go
Back start with nothing just touch no
penetration no penetration at all and
then from there until you feel right
when you feel my feet you should stop
you felt my feet before
that back no nothing and right when you
feel there it is and that's where you
stop and that's where you hang out just
hang out there you're hanging out there
I'm hanging out there okay that's the
that's his drill
one okay and then it's his
turn he'll get there he's basically
doing the staming meditation so to
speak he gets everything
going then again I start with just touch
no
penetration and then there you see how I
feel your feet right there not even
gripping yet but we're there and now
this is just your one this is where I
want you to stop hang out there for a
little while feel
that okay try to the next drill
progression two
here okay you line it up and again now I
want you to stop right on contact right
when you feel the feet okay with you and
me you should feel like right when your
fingers touch you should be able to feel
that got it okay so he's gonna get there
it's before that what I mean is I feel
you touch and then I feel you increase
but you should have felt it before that
okay so maybe slow down a little bit so
you're not like driving in the car and
volume okay why don't you park the damn
car and then maybe turn it a tiny bit
okay all
right so he goes right there it is right
maybe a little more there you go okay
and now we're he going to hang out there
and he's going to keep that value that
pressure he feels in his hands and in
his feet he's going to start releasing
all tension don't lose the pressure
though I'm going to start releasing all
muscle tension too more and more keep
releasing more if you pay ATT
the pressure at the hands
got higher higher rate higher volume
higher pressure see that the more I
release that's more pressure right there
increase it the
hands and just keep
releasing you're basically doing a
paired standing meditation right now
just keep releasing all
tension release it
all releasing
it at how much pressure right now at the
hands do you feel that right watch this
I'm keep there I'm going to really like
like pressure just up whoa you
see good look how much is actually there
right
now
okay all
right as you go I'm on you you're just
basically keep standing for muscle
tension and let muscle tension okay I
don't know if you're going to get to
where you feel it increases pressure
because it gets pretty freaking
significant at the end it felt
like this much pressure right without
you actually physically doing it
okay don't worry about that whether you
feel that or not maybe you're staying at
the same same level as in progression
one but we're getting rid of all that
unnecessary residual tension muscle
flexion okay as you're trying to go now
the hard part for you is going to be
that you relax and everything goes so
there's a caveat there release the
muscle tension without decreasing the
pressure from progression one okay all
right let's try
okay so we're going to do the third
progression for and this is for your
levels okay for where you're at and the
and the difficulties that we've had to
get here okay got it um all right so we
get into it going speed it up a little
bit be soft there okay
um so as we get there we're going to
quickly release go ahead and release as
fast as you can cool there's the
increase in pressure okay and now what
I'm going to do is take the weight
that's on the back
foot I feel that pressure I try to keep
that pressure in our contact he tries to
keep it and I'm just going to slowly
shift under the front foot and you feel
the increase in pressure okay cuz
externally I'm increasing the Y
okay so I'm on the back foot we're going
to we do it a little quicker but here we
go feel my
feet okay feel release
quick okay there we
are there's the pressure increase okay
and now I just going to keep this I
don't need you to fight me just don't
shut off okay keep the value and then
I'm just going to move keeping the value
very slowly very slowly keeping the
value don't go off of it okay and then I
go back so I'm going to need to coach
you a little bit here go down back down
back down back down back down
okay oh there's the pressure
okay no don't fight it let it move your
Center but don't move with it
switch wait
slower wait wait I'll tell you
when release drop tension tension
okay now
slowly shift weit slowly and this is
what I'm
doing okay you move me go back here's
what you
did you see that you
yielded first one you fought
it I just let you move that
value let's do it again back down come
on in
release
right right we're going to do it at
lighter
value slowly you feel the increase yep
and let it go okay so the two caveats
here is when he's externally increasing
the yawn don't brace that okay just keep
the value that you had that you were
given okay and then the other one is
don't deviate out of it let it let it
move you let it move
you okay got it okay go